- Добрий день! Добрий день! Нормально?
В полі роботи, культиватор?
Харашо. Так само. Дощ нема.
Німецький фермер Йоганн Венцль уже давно
знайшов спільну мову з українськими селянами.
16 років тому баварець заснував на Черкащині
своє фермерське господарство - товариство "Дукра агро".
На українських землях німець вирощує пшеницю,
кукурудзу, сою, соняшник, ріпак та цукровий буряк.
Місцеві пайщики охоче віддають Венцлю в оренду свої землі,
а обробляти їх допомагають 40 робітників із навколишніх селищ.
Селяни кажуть, що німецький фермер неабияк змінив їхнє життя.
Так вони ще ніколи не працювали:
усе за чіткими правилами і з гідною погодинною оплатою.
Наприклад, трактористи можуть отримувати
за вирахуванням податків в середньому не менше 15 тисяч гривень.
Є чіткий робочий графік: із 8 до 17.
Обід за розкладом - о 12-й, - і навіть є перерви на каву.
На підприємстві цінують пунктуальних.
Із тими, хто вживає алкоголь, одразу прощаються,
як і з тими, хто хоче щось поцупити.
Тракторист Олександр уже 8 років працює на Йоганна Венцля.
- Заробітну плату платять вчасно.
Поважають, як до людей ставляться.
Все змінив, навів порядок у селі, й на полях, і скрізь.
Чистота, чистота, чистота.
Він привчає нас так, як в них усе,
щоб не викидати сміття.
Особливо місцевих вражає те, що німець часто
й сам збирає сміття й каміння в полі, і привчає робити це робітників.
Усе, аби техніка не псувалася.
Для цього Йоганн Венцль навіть замінив
зруйновану асфальтну дорогу до своїх складів бетонною.
- Раніше тут стояв пил. Ми самі мішали бетон
і кожного дня робили по шматку. Десь за два тижні
впоралися. Це не те, що не можна оплатити.
Баварець вважає за потрібне постійно проводити
навчання для своїх робітників, аби вони вміли
працювати на його сучасній техніці і дотримувалися
правил роботи в полі. Це те, на що в Україні
часто не звертають уваги. Наприклад,
їздити по старих коліях не слід.
- Сюда їхати. Сюда. Яма неть їхати.
Яма- чуть-чуть болото.
Другий трактор так само говорити.
Раніше Венцль мав свій аграрний бізнес у Німеччині,
однак усе змінила стаття в одному з журналів
про умови аграрного бізнесу в Україні.
Він настільки зацікавився, що одразу приїхав
знайомитися з українськими реаліями.
Каже, що було нелегко.
Працювати ось тут, де колись пролягав чумацький шлях,
він вирішив, орієнтуючись на позицію
місцевої влади, яка демонструвала зацікавленість
в іноземних інвесторах і сприяла цьому.
У 2003-му Венцль взяв в оренду перші паї
місцевих жителів - близько 1200 гектарів.
Перший урожай, згадує, був  катастрофічним.
Довелося мати справу з хворим,
закисленим  ґрунтом, який виснажили бур’яни,
які росли тут багато років.
- Це вапно, яке ми беремо з відходів цукрової фабрики.
Кожні п’ять років вносимо. Це добре і для землі,
і для рослин.
Так ми оздоровлюємо ґрунт.
Перший добрий урожай німцю вдалося отримати
лише через 5 років: у 2008-му.
Нині він орендує вже втричі більші землі -
4200 гектарів. Селяни вже хочуть віддавати
в оренду свої паї лише йому, хоча в районі є і великі,
і середні українські господарства.
- Ми отримували мізер. Ми взагалі нічого не отримували.
Якщо брати середній пай 3,10 гектарів,
то ми отримували 3500,
а зараз ми отримуємо 16-17 тисяч .
То це ж є різниця! І люди всі задоволені, тим більше старі люди.
Ці жінки займаються обліком земель.
На Черкащині зараз жваво обговорюють
тему земельної реформи.
Чи треба в Україні дозволити продаж сільгоспземель у принципі
і чи треба землі продавати іноземцям.
У жінок уже давно є відповідь.
- Я не за продаж. Я за те, щоб земля залишилася при собі.
- Бог його знає, як його правильно сказати.
Людині наче не можна заборонити продавати свою землю,
але ми тільки не за продаж землі.
- Якщо от такий господар, як Йоганн Венцль,
то хай приходять, нехай хазяйнують.
Нехай наводять лад, бо ми самі його не можемо навести.
У селі Роги згадують, як колись паї в оренду взяв американець
і землі стояли кілька років у бур’янах.
Таке, каже сільський голова Валерій Івасюк, тут не потрібно.
Він узагалі проти продажу земель - і українцям, і іноземцям.
- Моє бачення таке, щоб ця земля стала товаром,
але покупцем могла бути тільки держава
і міські селищні ради
ці землі могли скуповувати назад у комунальну власність.
Інвестор має отримувати тільки на умовах оренди.
Йоганн Венцль вважає, що тему ризиків від продажу земель
не слід драматизувати. Цим шляхом до України
пройшли багато країн.
У німецькій культурі землекористування
продаж землі відбувається, якщо сталося
щось катастрофічне. Німці роблять усе, аби
не втратити щорічний прибуток зі своїх ділянок.
- Гадаю, що в Україні ще повинні добре обмізкувати
й обговорити, як відкрити ринок землі так, щоб це було вигідно.
Я раджу всім місцевим жителям
не позбуватися паїв, а заробляти на них.
Звичайно, якщо власники паїв, які ми орендуємо,
захочуть їх продати, ми купимо.
Водночас, зауважує Венцль,
скуповувати українські землі він не планує.
Оренди цілком достатньо.
Так само вважає і його гість і колега,
фермер зі Швейцарії Моріц Штамм.
У 2005 році він приїхав на Черкащину на практику до Венцля і зрозумів,
що навряд чи зможе на швейцарських землях
мати такий урожай, як в Україні.
Тож і він скористався шансом заснувати в регіоні
своє товариство, яке нині орендує вже 2800 гектарів.
- З грошима допомогли мої батьки.
Вони взяли кредит удома, у Швейцарії.
Це для нас - іноземців в Україні - одна з переваг, що
ми можемо взяти більш вигідні кредити на батьківщині: під 1-2%.
Зокрема через дешеві кредити іноземні інвестори
мають кращі шанси купити землю, ніж їхні конкуренти - українські фермери.
Принаймні, цього бояться багато селян-підприємців.
Йоганн Венцль, утім, сумнівається, що
такі страхи виправдані. По-перше, в Німеччині
навряд чи знайдеться багато банків, готових дати
кредити на аграрний бізнес в Україні,
та й інтерес іноземних аграріїв до України,
за спостереженнями Венцля та Штамма, за останні роки спав.
Йоганн Венцль зізнається, що його шлях
до нинішнього успіху був складний.
Він навіть написав про це книгу.
У цьому вагончику німець жив цілий рік, поки
зруйнована колишня радгоспна будівля ремонтувалася.
Для свого бізнесу підприємець із нуля побудував
і сушарку, і склади, аби мати повний цикл виробництва.
Водночас німець має намір ще довго працювати
в Україні й не приховує задоволення від того, що робить.